man of Madonna is the first chapter in
the dark pictures anthology a series
brought to us by supermassive games the
developer of cult classic until dawn and
is trying something quite ambitious and
a little bit different I am tamal I'm
Adam and we have played the game and
we're going to tell you a little bit of
what we thought importance say this is a
preview version of the game that we're
basing my impressions on so things could
change but it was a pretty good
indication of what the game is gonna be
we paid about an hour another hop and a
half right yeah it was about maybe a
third of the game I say but yeah the big
surprise so everyone's thinking this is
kind of like a single-player narrative
driven horror game but the twist is you
can play it in multiplayer call a co-op
well there was a variety of different
modes so obviously you can play the
whole thing in a single player solo only
and that we asked them and they said it
will be between about five to six hours
yeah it'll take us complete it then the
main mode then this what me and Sam got
to play is a sort of co-op narrative
where you are yeah well you're both
playing in the same story we'll go into
a little bit more detail on that in a
second and then the follow mode that we
we saw was called movie night mode which
I think's based on a lot of people's
experiences of until dawn where they
would watch you play that as a group
yeah so the developers said that that
was directly the kind of impetus behind
creating this mode there people used to
gather around a screen and play until
dawn together so they thought why not
just build that into the game so you get
this movie night mode and that was I
believe two to five players and I think
the way that worked was that you all at
the beginning of the game would select a
character yeah one of the five
characters if you didn't have five
players you could double up on the
characters yeah and then when that
character came to be you know you know
as the player you'd pass it off yeah and
roll around one controller with multiple
characters which creates a zone
interesting both plus points and
downsides but we'll get into that later
so to lay the groundwork a bit the main
inspiration for this story in terms of
themes and atmosphere is to kind of
classic genres which is home invasion
and also ghost ship classic ghost ship
stories yeah it's kind of a weird sort
of
merger of the two subgenres and for me
it didn't always work like those two
don't so naturally fit together in my
head maybe that's just me but yes we got
a sort of taste of both but not like the
full extent I would say of the ghostship
horror new actually looks like it's
gonna be maybe the latter half of the
game and I reckon I'll probably go all
in on that yeah but we got a lot of yeah
we got a lot of setup we've got a lot of
build up where so you sort of see the
sort of central go ship or you know the
origins I guess that go ship and then
and then we're with our sort of five
main playable characters yeah on a board
sort of a smaller boat they're just off
in searching yes so they're going for
diving yeah so you get a bunch of
characters which are kind of archetypal
and kind of like for that genre and the
kind of the interactions between them
are what the majority of what we play it
right because police doesn't want to do
the thing Conrad's kind of like I've got
the money you can do what we want by
he's also kind of got the hots for flesh
yeah
Alex and Julia are a couple but they've
got a little bit of tension there's like
their relationships are tearing apart
the seams is yeah and then the younger
brother yeah kind of like he's there for
the ride and she's trying to fit in and
have a good time and you want to play it
cool so he doesn't show up his older
brother yeah the same time so like
you're trying to the interactions are in
that kind of like context yeah it's sort
of sowing the seeds for like what you're
probably going to see with these
relationships sort of expanding across
the narrative and like crucially there
are a lot of moments in the section that
we played where it would say
relationship status updated or you know
which great update or traits updated as
well like where your decisions your
choices sort of affect how your
relationships sort of evolve and grow
with the other characters and I guess
that's where we're gonna start to see
which characters sort of live or die
here in the second half of the game we
can't just finally attack them
we need a plan that can take them a lot
of months we need to get free first
things first
so how that all kind of connects to the
central multiplayer can see is we were
playing online yeah we weren't actually
like far apart we were on the same in
the same area ish but we were connected
via and the online connection and
internet connection and what would
happen is like I would say something in
a conversation and you would be in that
same setting you were in the room or on
the boat nearby me the actual boat is
quite small which makes sense because
you don't want a massive area yeah so
there were situations where we would be
part of the same conversation
conversating with each other yeah or I
would be having a conversation and you
would be doing something else in the
same area yeah it felt like quite
similar to the last year's a way out in
that regard so like where you have these
environments where you're both free to
kind of explore and talk to people and
you know just kind of progressed your
little narrative going on so the good
part that I found was it's one of the
few times where I actually felt like I
was having a conversation with another
person yes please so when I was talking
to your character yeah it felt like we
were having a bit of a conversation you
had enough agency to say something that
I wouldn't explain and then I would have
to try and react to that and define how
our relationship is or define who my
character is yeah and I'd say from like
a mechanical point of view like that
sort of game plays for the
moment-to-moment stuff it all felt
really quite smooth it didn't like feel
like you were waiting too long on the
other player yeah or you know it didn't
feel like this story wasn't progressing
because someone was doing one thing
while the other person was doing another
I think the only moment we felt a bit
like luck it hit a snag when there was
an action involved at the same time so
if it's like reach out to help this
person and then someone else is on the
other side I wasn't privy to what was
happening on the ascent but there was
one point where I was like try and save
someone and I couldn't tell whether on
the oh and he was taking quite a long
time so I'd like my hand out into this
like dark corner on the other side I
think you were making a decision or the
other character was making a decision
decision whether to take my hand or do
something else yeah yeah
so it was lucky just long enough of a
pause to be like the sign of the office
but in the actual conversating it felt
quite natural just yeah it kind of the
immersion is there and it kind of pulls
you in and start to get into the
the conversation which felt good
definitely I'd say where it doesn't feel
as smooth is more the storytelling side
of things which you would kind of assume
is where supermassive games after well
you know their success with uh until
dawn would be really comfortable with
but we found the pacing of the story and
some of the dialogue to be maybe a
little lacking come here Dixon the
writing of the dialogue feels quite
awkward and then some of the delivery of
it feels quite awkward as well
tilted isn't yeah and then that kind of
permeates almost every interaction that
I yes and Lee there was at least one or
two lines that felt like clangers yeah
they would just come out of nowhere and
it'd just be like that's not something
that real humans like I suppose it kind
of plays into what that's sort of when
you had until dawn where it's sort of
quite sort of schlocky it's so bad it's
good sort of norm you know like it's fun
and that kind of like they're also like
moments this there's some good writing
there's rolling I felt Flis was quite
strongly characterized yeah and her
dialogue options kind of fit into what
she was going with she never felt like
tonally all over the place no but like
the thing that kind of stuck out to me
was it felt like those characters could
have been in until dawn yeah and to me
that was kind of like a bit of a
whiplash in tone in terms of tone I kept
thinking at any point this could be this
could go from like depending on my
dialogue atrocity could feel like a
horror
you know thriller type thing or it can
feel like this is about to become a
American Pie or something yeah and I was
like that I don't think that's what
they're going for
I think crucially like despite you know
shortcomings with some of the plot
elements and the dialogue I do want to
see where the story goes I do want to
know I am invested in it now so I do
want to you know see what happens like
so what our demo ended at what felt like
you know the start of the story yeah and
I like that's where you find them add an
like you yes obviously the thing that
happens is the main kind of like
inciting incident is a bunch of pirates
show up and take off the ship and it's
it's a proper like you know look at me
I'm the captain now moment yeah but in
that scenario is route like weird stuff
was happening and weird not like because
of spooky stuff but it was like
in terms of the scenario was weird where
you'd all get tied up and then the
pirates would do things like just come
and take you and be like you come with
me and you're like oh it's about to kick
off and they'd take you out and just
like walk around for a bit and then
bring you back yeah you got taken out
didn't you no I stayed in the room where
so everyone's game yeah and you went out
and so I wish I'm gagging anyone else I
could ungag if you you were in the room
on gagging everyone yeah
which means like which was weird because
like you're wasting a lot of time there
yeah and the the kind of like pirates
don't respond to the fact that everyone
back everyone's own gagged
yeah I was outside as Fliss and the
pirate captain who's got a weird gammy
eye and he looks like a pirate captain
he's like call for a weather report
because there's like a storm coming yeah
so like I picked up the phone and I
called and my choices were to like just
ask for the weather I'll be like we've
been kidnapped
yeah and I went we've we've been
kidnapped and then he like pushed me
down and I was like please I'm sorry I
don't see any this is the interesting
yeah like there's scenarios that because
it's multiplayer co-op there's that
moment like where you have a discussion
because you did a diving section yeah I
did a whole different section yeah and
like even with other people that we
spoke to about who you played the game
we were sort of having completely
different outcomes to the end of our
demo so for instance in our demo you
managed to escape this Conrad onto
another onto the Pirates boat and then
go out get away and you can choose not
to do that but I did it because you told
me to yeah and there's the character as
Alex you were like go for the boat and
get someone yeah so I would have my my
innate thing would have been like as
mean on my more would be trying to stop
and stay there and try and fight it yeah
but because you said it I was awful yeah
I'm gonna do what and then and then back
on the boat with with my character I had
to to stop the pirates from shooting you
yeah so like they didn't see that it has
told me press triangle to dodge button I
realized that I was dodging it yeah and
it went far off because you had done
something about that yeah that's really
really interested in saying and like
that's the part of it like conceptually
on a mechanical and design level I think
it's a really really interesting
fascinating yeah I think as well like in
the slither that we saw like it was
interesting to extrapolate that into the
second half the game where it's probably
gonna get much more life or death yeah I
think those decisions that real humans
we'll be the this the the signing
factors between who lives and dies and I
think you'd be both fun and frustrating
for whoever's on the receive luckily
unlike we should say like I'm interested
in seeing how the pacing works because
we played like an hour and a half yeah
and it had very little spooky stuff yeah
it was more thriller than horror and
like the game as a tourist they say is
five hours when we get to the ship it's
gonna have to pop off straightaway
yeah like immediately and it's gonna
have to maintain that for three or four
hours and definitely I think I think
we're in agreement we're like the actual
idea of it and how it played and kind of
be what the opportunity of gameplay
opportunities looks like is setting up
already really interesting and appealing
the kind of the writing and perhaps the
acting of it is not as big yeah the
movie night aspect of it yeah we played
a bit of there and we watched a lot of
people play as well just to see how it
would like unfold on a normal scenario
and it looks like it does the trick like
you play for a bit my only concern was
there are extended segments where one
character is just playing on his own
yeah we had a group of four people or
five people sitting around a TV and
someone playing as Alex was going for
like 15 minutes and which is a lot of
time but I guess the natural like Cowell
point of that is like it's also a
viewing experience for everyone else
exactly yeah I can still try them up and
be like no don't do that and I think
what you were saying about certain
choices and betrayals is probably gonna
be sort of amplified in that mode we
could save one person is playing one
character what happens if that character
gets like left behind
yeah then like oh like they're not
active anymore they're just a viewer
yeah and there's definitely be angry and
sore yeah exactly yeah
gun dances shut your mouth
you shut your mouth so like the idea
that it's just an anthology series like
black mirror or the twilight zone but
for videogames I think a really
interesting one and I think each each of
the games that they're going to do and
they say they're gonna do about two
every 12 months yeah I think two per
year yeah I think like the idea that
each is gonna be a different slice of
horror so like how we've now got home
invasion meets ghost story
Yoshi a story different yeah the next
one could be like a teen slasher like we
had with until dawn they're not linked
other than the one you're a curator
character the curator is something that
we haven't mentioned and but yeah but
like he's basically the he's the Peter
Stormare character from until though
he's kind of like the Crypt Keeper from
you know it tells from the Crypt where
he's somehow able to see your decisions
yeah and he's like commenting and also
like recapping things and the writing on
him was good noting that he is probably
the strongest read character because
he's doing things like nudging you and
being like should you do this so she
don't do that so like he knows he's
apparently been sort of writing or
collecting stories for thousands of
years and he says he can't remember when
he started and like he is sort of
observing you and commenting on you and
saying oh you made that decision did you
what about maybe this and I so I don't
know how that will affect gameplay or
your decisions or your choices obviously
he can maybe sort of suggest to you what
you should be doing but I think yeah
you're right he was he was well written
and well acted he's the link between all
the story stories it doesn't seem like
what the way they talked about it was
like he's not going to tie these all
together in a way that you go oh that's
what this episode meant in this one yeah
but he's just kind of like the link
between all of them he's going to be the
avenue which you explore all these
stories yeah so he's the anchor for the
dark pictures anthology but yeah I'm
excited to see more yeah yeah and we've
got more about the game on GameSpot calm
where I've got a few interviews with the
developers which you can read about and
get insight into how they make the game
and also kind of their vision for the
next few episodes in this series but
yeah let us know what you're thinking
about man of Madden and whether you're
excited for it what kind of way you want
to play it now that
that is co-op single player and movie
night yelled all the might and you can
do that in the comments or you can find
us on Twitter I'm at two more age I'm at
Adam riess pace and we'll see you next
time